gesetzt waren der vorsitzende und der
berichterstatter drei kolleginnen oder
kollegen wurden zugelost
das sind die drei kollegen die sie hier
sehen
auch der rest hat an der entscheidung
mitgewirkt die entscheidung ist mit
sieben zu eins stimmen ergangen die wir
gleich verkünden werden
wir wollten nur sichergehen dass wir
hier genügend abstand halten können und
ich hoffe auch sie werden weiter
genügend abstand halten
ich möchte sie jetzt auch schon bitten
bereits nach der verkündung irgendwelche
gespräche stattfinden was ja möglich ist
nach verkündung dass sie bitte den
abstand einhalten dass sie auf sich
achten und dass sie bei einigen auf die
anderen achten erschienen sind für die
beschwerdeführer der
verfassungsbeschwerde 2 bevor er 859 aus
2015 verdoppelt heinrich weiss würden
sie bitte stehen
dankeschön und herr dr patrick adenauer
sowie als bevollmächtigter herr
professor doktor christoph degenhart
für die beschwerdeführer
verfassungsbeschwerde 2 bvr 16 51 aus
2015 herr professor dr bernd lucke und
frau ulrike treviso sowie also freue
mich daher professor dr hans fetscher
vorn
für die beschwerdeführer der
verfassungsbeschwerde 2 bvr 2006 aus
herr dr peter gauweiler sowie als
bevollmächtigter herr professor dr
dietrich musik für die beschwerdeführer
der verfassungsbeschwerde 2 bvr 980 aus
herr professor dr johann heinrich von
stein frau dagmar metzger herr otto
michels sowie als bevor ich mich da herr
professor dr markus kerber für die
bundesregierung aus dem
bundesministerium der finanzen herr
staatssekretär dr gehört cookies und vor
ministerialdirigent dr judith hermes
es sieht folgendes urteil verkündet
im namen des volkes arabisch erstens die
verfahren 2 bvr 859 bis 2015 24 16 51
aus 2015 2 bvr 2006 aus 2015 und zwar
980 aus 2016 werden zur gemeinsamen
entscheidung verbundenen arabisch
zweitens die verfassungsbeschwerden der
beschwerdeführer zu bullish erstens
gegen die beschwerde gegenstände zu
arabisch zweitens und drittens die
verfassungsbeschwerde der
beschwerdeführer zur römisch zweitens
gegen die beschwerde gegenstand zu
arabisch erstens sowie die
verfassungsbeschwerden der
beschwerdeführer zurückgeschnitten
werden verworfen arabisch drittens
bundesregierung und hinsichtlich der
beschwerdeführer zu komisch ersten
römisch zweitens braucht der deutsche
bundestag haben die beschwerdeführer zur
römisch erstens und römisch zweitens und
römisch drittens in ihrem recht aus
artikel 38 absatz 1 satz 1 in verbindung
mit artikel 20 absatz 1 und berg satz 2
in verbindung mit artikel 79 absatz 3
des grundgesetzes verletzt da sie es
unterlassen haben geigte maßnahmen
dagegen zu ergreifen dass der rat der
europäischen zentralbank kleinen
beschluss 2015 auf 774 der europäischen
zentralbank vom vierten märz 2015 über
ein programm zum ankauf von wertpapieren
des öffentlichen sektors an den
sekundärmärkten geändert durch beschluss
2015 21.01 der europäischen zentralbank
von 5 november 2015 durch beschluss 2015
2464 vom 16 dezember 2015 durch
beschluss 2016 702 von 18 april 2016 und
durch beschluss 2017 100 vom elften
januar 2017 weder geprüft noch dargelegt
hat dass die beschlossenen maßnahmen dem
grundsatz der verhältnismäßigkeit
im übrigen werden die
verfassungsbeschwerden zurückgewiesen
dann ist arabisch drittens fünfter
die bundesrepublik deutschland hat den
beschwerdeführern zurück erstens
zweitens drittens ihre notwendigen
auslagen zu erstatten
bitte nehmen sie platz
meine damen und herren das vorliegende
urteil ist keine leichte kost
erstmals in seiner geschichte stellt das
bundesverfassungsgericht fest dass
handlungen und entscheidungen
europäische organe offensichtlich nicht
von der europäischen kompetenzordnung
gedeckt sind und daher in deutschland
keine wirksamkeit entfalten können
man spricht insofern von ultra bieres
akten für viele kenner der materie
dürfte die entscheidung indes keine
überraschung sein weil sie den
wahrscheinlich nur vorläufigen endpunkt
einer längeren und absehbaren
entwicklung markiert worum geht es zwar
das sogenannte public sektor purchase
program psp ist teil eines
rahmenprogramms des euro systems zum
ankauf von vermögenswerten
dass sich expert asset purchase program
vpp nennt aus reichlich ausweis nicht
seiner begründung zieht das gap auf eine
ausweitung der geldmenge
hierdurch sollen konsum und
investitionen gefördert und die
inflationsrate in der eurozone auf knapp
unter zwei prozent erhöht werden das psp
wurde durch beschluss der europäischen
zentralbank vom vierten jahr 2015 ins
leben gerufen der in der folgezeit durch
fünf weitere beschlüsse geändert wurde
mit dem psp werden unter im einzelnen
festgelegten rahmenbedingungen in erster
linie staatsanleihen erworben die von
den zentralregierung der
euro-mitgliedstaaten ausgegeben werden
zum 8 november 2009 10 hatte das euro
system im rahmen des erp wertpapiere im
gesamtwert von 2.500 57 milliarden euro
erworben wo von circa 2000 88 milliarden
euro auf das psp in vielen
die beschwerdeführer machen mit ihren
verfassungsbeschwerden gelten dass das
psp gegen das verbot monetäre
staatsfinanzierung und das prinzip der
begrenzten einzelermächtigung verstoße
weil die ezb die europäische zentralbank
für dieses programm über kein mandat
verfügen die ezb betreibe keine
währungspolitik sondern sie betreibe
wirtschaftspolitik die den
mitgliedstaaten vorbehalten zeugen das
bundesverfassungsgericht gibt den
verfassungsbeschwerden mit der heutigen
entscheidung überwiegend statt
obwohl der gerichtshof der europäischen
union in seinem urteil vom 11
dezember 2018 die maßnahmen für
europarechtskonform erachtet hat bei
damen und herren in zeiten wie diesen in
denen die europäische solidarität in nie
dagewesener weise herausgefordert wird
macht die heutige entscheidung auf den
ersten blick irritierend löschen
deshalb ist es mir besonders wichtig
einige einleitende bemerkungen zu machen
das ist ziemlich mit drei kurzen
feststellung die ich sozusagen vor die
klammer ziel beginnen erstens aktuelle
finanzielle hilfsmaßnahmen der
europäischen union oder der ezb im
zusammenhang mit der gegenwärtigen krise
sind nicht gegenstand dieser
entscheidung
zweitens soweit deutschen
verfassungsorgane behörden und gerichte
durch die entscheidung verpflichtet
werden der bisherigen handhabung des psp
durch das eurosystem und die ezb
entgegenzutreten betrifft dies lediglich
die verpflichtung der ezb eine
verhältnismäßigkeitsprüfung vorzunehmen
und entsprechend zu dokumentieren
hier werden insofern keine
handlungsmöglichkeiten von vornherein
aus der hand geschlagen
insbesondere einen verstoß gegen das
verbot der monetären
haushaltsfinanzierung konnte der senat
nicht feststellen
es kommt hier jeweils auf die konkrete
ausgestaltung der maßnahme
drittens
die idee der europäischen
rechtsgemeinschaft verliert in der krise
nichts an ihrer bedeutung im gegenteil
um die krise und ihre folgen nachhaltig
zu bewältigen brauchen wir das recht als
festes gemeinsames fundament die seit
jeher bestehenden diskussion und
auseinandersetzung zwischen den
nationalen verfassungsgerichten und dem
original weil die grenzen der
europäischen kompetenzordnung sind
konstituierender teil dieser lebendigen
europäischen rechtsgemeinschaft das
bundesverfassungsgericht ist sich
bewusst dass entscheidung ist nur in
absoluten ausnahmefällen die
gefolgschaft versagt bleiben darf und
hat insoweit eine ganze reihe von
einschneidenden kriterien in den letzten
jahren entwickelt die von der mehrzahl
der verfassungsgerichte der
mitgliedstaaten der sache nach
anerkannten möglichkeiten der
verfassungsgerichtlichen identitäts und
ultra bieres kontrolle verloren aber
ihren sinn wenn sie niemals erfolg haben
dürften
die vorgeschichte der heutigen
entscheidung beginnt vor mehr als sechs
jahren ausgehend von mehreren
verfassungsbeschwerde verfahren hatte
das bundesverfassungsgericht zweifeln ob
das so genannte u mt programm der ezb
mit den vorgaben des europarechts
vereinbart ist mit beschluss vom 14
januar 2014 nächste ist jetzt senat
daher erstmals im europäischen
gerichtshof einige fragen zur
vorabentscheidung vor er folgt dem senat
nicht im ergebnis nahm aber zentrale
aussagen des vorlagebeschluss es auf
entgegen der auffassung vieler
mitgliedsstaaten stellte er insbesondere
fest dass das handeln der ezb der
gerichtlichen kontrolle unterliegt
aus sicht des bundesverfassungsgerichts
begegnete die begründung die
entscheidung zwar erheblichen einwenden
die der senat auch deutlich formulierte
angesichts der rechtlichen einigung des
handelns der ezb durch eine reihe von
parametern war das
bundesverfassungsgericht die grenze zu
einem trabi go sagt aber noch nicht für
überschritten an und führte versehen mit
verschiedenen sicherungsmaßnahmen die
verfassungs- und unionsrechtlichen
rechtskreis
in seinem urteil vom 21 juni 2016
zusammen
das vorliegende psp verfahren knüpft an
dieses urteil an
mit beschluss vom 18 juni 2017 hat der
senat dem europäischen gerichtshof
erneut mehrere fragen zur
vorabentscheidung vorgelegt diese
betrafen insbesondere das verbot
monetäre haushaltsfinanzierung das
mandat der ezb für die währungspolitik
und einen möglichen übergriff in die
zuständigkeit und haushalt so hat der
mitgliedstaaten mit rot vom hälften
dezember 2018 hat der eugh entschieden
dass das psp nicht über das mandat der
ezb hinausgehe und auch nicht gegen das
verbot der monetären
haushaltsfinanzierung verstoßen
in der mündlichen verhandlung von 30 31
juli im letzten jahr haben wir diese
entscheidung und die dort vorgenommenen
modifikationen des ursprünglichen
maßstabs eingehend erwartet das ergebnis
ist für den senat nach intensiver
beratung eindeutig wie einstiegen
beschlüsse des rates der europäischen
zentralbank sind trotz des
anderslautendes urteil des gerichtshofs
offensichtlich nicht mit den vorgaben
des europarechts vereinbaren zur
begründung seiner entscheidung im senat
in zwei schritten vor
in einem ersten schritt setzt er sich
mit der bindekraft der entscheidung des
europäischen gerichtshof auseinander
in einem zweiten schritt mit der
handhabung des psp durch die ezb
zunächst zum ersten schritt
die voraussetzungen der rotavirus
kontrolle sind in der rechtsprechung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts seit längerem
erklärt seine pflicht substantiiert 'nen
rügen eines ultra wie ihres handelns der
europäischen organe und einrichtungen
nachzugehen hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht mit der
vertraglich dem gericht zur übertragenen
aufgabe zu koordinieren
die europäischen verträge auszulegen und
anzuwenden und dabei die einheit und
kohärenz des unionsrechts zu warten die
herausforderungen und gefahren liegen
insofern auf der hand wenn jeder
mitgliedstaat ohne weiteres für sich in
anspruch nehme durch eigene gerichte
über die gültigkeit von rechtsakten der
union zu entscheiden
während der anwendungs vorrang und die
einheitliche anwendung des unionsrechts
gefährt würden aber andererseits den
mitgliedstaaten als herren der verträge
vollständig auf die ultra - kontrolle
verzichten
so müssten sie selbst solche
entscheidungen und handlungen von unions
organen akzeptieren die offensichtlich
auf eine vertragsänderung oder klarer
kompetenzausweitung hinausliefen wie auf
dieser situation resultierende in
gewisser weise unvermeidliche spannungs
lage ist im einklang mit der
europäischen integration city kooperativ
auszugleichen und durch wechselseitige
rücksichtnahmen zu entschärfen
genau diese vorgehensweise kennzeichnet
die zusammenarbeit der europäischen
union als staaten als verfassungs es
verwaltungs und als rechtsprechungs
verbund die auslegung und anwendung des
unionsrechts einschließlich der
bestimmungen der dabei anzuwendenden
methode ist so fördert aufgabe des
europäischen gerichtshofs ihm obliegt es
bei der auslegung und anwendung der
verträge das recht zu wahren
es ist vor diesem hintergrund nicht
aufgabe des bundesverfassungsgerichts
bei auslegungsfragen im unionsrecht die
auch bei methoden gerechter bewältigung
im üblichen rechtswissenschaftlichen
diskussions rahmen zu verschiedenen
ergebnissen führen können seine
auslegung an die stelle der jähnigen des
gerichtshofs zu setzen
es muss die entscheidung des
gerichtshofs vielmehr auch dann
respektieren wenn dieser zu einer
auffassung gelangt der sich mit
gewichtigen argumenten entgegentreten
wieso allerdings gilt dies nur
soweit sich die entscheidung auf
anerkannte methodische grundsätze
zurückführen lässt und nicht objektiv
willkürlich erscheint im vorliegenden
fall ist diese grenze überschritten
die auffassung des gerichtshofs die
beschlüsse des ezb rates über das pvp
sein noch von den kompetenzen der ezb
gedeckt verkennt in offensichtlicher
weise bedeutung und tragweite des bei
der kompetenzverteilung zu beachtenden
grundsatzes der verhältnismäßigkeit der
ansatz des gerichtshofs bei der
verhältnismäßigkeitsprüfung die
tatsächlichen wirkung einer maßnahmen
außer acht zu lassen und auf eine
wertende gesamtbetrachtung zu verzichten
bis methodisch nicht mehr vertretbar und
verfehlt die anforderung an eine
nachvollziehbare überprüfung der
einhaltung des währungspolitischen
mandats des europäischen systems der
zentralbanken und der ezb bei dieser
handhabung kann der grundsatz der
verhältnismäßigkeit die ihm zukommende
korrektiv funktion zum schutz mitglied
staatlicher zuständigkeiten nicht
erfüllen was das prinzip der begrenzten
einzelermächtigung im grunde leer laufen
lässt in dem der gerichtshof hier seiner
kontrolle aufgabe nicht nachkommt
handelt gern und ramires da der senat
somit nicht an die entscheidung des
gerichtshofs gebunden ist hat er
eigenständig zu beurteilen ob die ezb
mit den beschlüssen zur errichtung und
durchführung des psp noch innerhalb
ihrer kompetenzen gehandelt hat das ist
offensichtlich nicht der fall weil die
ezb erwägungen zur verhältnismäßigkeit
nicht angestellt hat die beschlüsse
beschränken sich auf die feststellung
dass das angestrebte inflationsziel von
zwei prozent nicht erreicht sei und
weniger belastenden mittel nicht zur
verfügung stehen
sie enthalten keine prognose zu den
wirtschaftspolitischen auswirkungen des
programms sowie dazu ob sie in einem
angemessenen verhältnis zu dem
erstrebten währungspolitischen vorteilen
stehen
es ist nicht ersichtlich dass der ezb
rat die im psp angelegten und mit ihm
unmittelbar verbundenen folgen dieses
programm aufgrund seines volumens von
über zwei billionen euro
euro
einer laufzeit von mittlerweile mehr als
drei jahren zwangsläufig verursacht
erfasst und abgehoben hätte die
negativen auswirkungen des psp mit
wachsendem umfang und fortschreitender
dauer zu so dass sich mit der dauer auch
die anforderung an eine solche abwägung
erhöhen
das psp verbessert nicht nur die
refinanzierungsbedingungen der
mitgliedstaaten erheblich weil sich
diese zu deutlich günstigeren
konditionen kredite am kapitalmarkt
verschaffen können
das psp wirkt sich auch auf den
bankensektor aus indem es
risikobehaftete staatsanleihen in großem
umfang in die bilanzen des euro systems
übernimmt dadurch die wirtschaftliche
situation der banken verbessert und ihre
bonität erhöht
das hat erhebliche ökonomische
auswirkungen auf nahezu alle bürgerinnen
und bürger die als aktionäre als mieter
als eigentümer von immobilien als sparer
oder als versicherungsnehmer getroffen
sind
so ergeben sich etwa für sparvermögen
deutliche verlustrisiken während die
immobilienpreise überproportional
steigen
wirtschaftlich an sich nicht mehr
lebensfähige unternehmen bleiben
aufgrund des auch durch das psp
abgesenkten allgemeinen zinsniveaus
weiterhin am markt schließlich begibt
sich das euro system mit zunehmender
laufzeit des programms und steigendem
gesamtvolumen in eine erhöhte
abhängigkeit von der politik der
mitgliedsstaaten
weil es das psp immer weniger ohne
gefährdung der stabilität der
währungsunion beenden und rückabwickeln
kann diese und andere erhebliche
wirtschaftspolitische auswirkung hätte
die ezb gewichten mit den
prognostizierten vorteilen für die
erreichung des von ihr definierten
leeres politischen ziels in beziehung
setzen und nach verhältnismäßigkeit
gesichts kunden abwägen muss eine solche
abwägung ist soweit ersichtlich weder zu
beginn des programms noch zu einem
späteren zeitpunkt erfolgt ohne die
dokumentation
und wie diese abwägung stattgefunden hat
lässt sich die rechtliche einhaltung des
mandats der ezb gerichtlich nicht
effektiv kontrollieren zweiter
gerichtshof einen verstoß gegen das
verbot der monetären staatsfinanzierung
verneint begegnet die handhabung der in
seinen urteilen in der rechtssache
gauweiler entwickelten garantien für
einen ankaufsprogramm wieder oben
erheblichen methodischen einwänden der
senat sieht sich insofern aber an die
auffassung des gerichtshofs gebunden da
angesichts der realen möglichkeit dass
die vom gerichtshof anerkannten
garantien von der ezb eingehalten wurden
ein offensichtlicher verstoß gegen
artikel 123 absatz 1a eu v nicht
festgestellt werden kann
meine damen und herren was folgt aus
alledem für die deutschen staatsorgane
erstens bundesregierung und bundestag
sind aufgrund ihrer
integrationsverantwortung verpflichtet
auf eine verhältnismäßigkeitsprüfung
durch die ezb im rahmen des psp pärchen
zu drücken
entsprechendes gilt für die am ersten
januar 2009 10 goldene reh
investitionsphase des psp und seine
wiederaufnahme zum ersten november 2009
insoweit dauert auch die pflicht die
entscheidung des euro systems über
ankäufe von staatsanleihen unter dem psp
zu beobachten und mit den ihnen zu
gebote stehenden mittel auf die
einhaltung des ds zb zugewiesenen
mandats hinzuwirken fort zweiter der
bundesbank ist es untersagt nach einer
für die abstimmung im eurosystem
notwendigen übergangsfrist von höchstens
drei monaten an umsetzung und vollzug
der verfahrensgegenständlichen
beschlüsse weiter mitzuwirken
wenn nicht der ezb-rat in einem neuen
beschluss nachvollziehbar darlegt dass
die mit dem psp angestrebten
währungspolitischen ziele nicht außer
verhältnis zu den damit verbundenen
wirtschafts und fiskalpolitischen
auswirkungen stehen unter derselben
voraussetzung ist die bundesbank
verpflichtet für eine im rahmen des
euro-systems abgestimmte auch
langfristig angelegte rückführung der
bestände an staatsanleihen
sorge zu brauchen